ne yo gourd 100 produits laitiers
envahissent le marché
il est plus récents rapports importants
vont dans ce sens-là de diminuer la
consommation de protéines des étudiants
se disent mais je lui demande ce type de
produit là il l'a
[Musique]
prenez à la laiterie chalifoux à
suresnes on est en train de commencer
une production de hyogo végétalien en
fait on peut pas dire le mot you go ça
soit du popo fermenté cette laiterie
bientôt centenaire se lance dans une
production qui est particulière à base
de bois sont de lait de coco avec le
nouveau guide avec tout ce qui se passe
dans l'industrie laitière
même les employés ici ont été durs à
convaincre de faire un produit
végétalien parce qu'on on est des
aimants du lait on est rendus aux
végétaliens parce qu'il ya un mouvement
on sent la tendance ya la demande et on
est allé aussi découvrir en europe ce
mouvement le parti et dans l'est de coco
ça goûte très très bon au même moment
une autre laiterie cette fois aux états
unis
giovanni lance elle aussi une gamme de
produits végétaux en europe aux
etats-unis au canada
l'offre grandi et les réseaux sociaux
s'emballe moins deux potes ma carrière
après 25 ans je pensais le croisic qui
est parti le plus rapidement tout le
monde était comme en anglais la frénésie
sur les médias sociaux si c'est quelque
chose pour le produit souvent la
tendance végétalienne les allergies les
intolérances l'environnement l'éthique
animale ou simplement pour varier sont
différentes raisons de choisir un
substitut aux young ur de lait de vache
les versions végétales sont faites à
base de soya coco amandes noix en fait
de boissons végétales de toutes sortes
c'est difficile parce que comparer un yo
gourd les ingrédients sont différents
pour donner la texture il a fallu qu'on
rajoute de l'amidon il a donc la
fermentation se produit là n'est pas la
même n'est pas comparable à celle d'un
die ugur ya juste champagne charpin il
ya beaucoup de vins effervescents au
début puis on peut même déforester co2
mais ça ce chemin champagne denis roy et
vice-doyen et chercheurs il nous
explique la définition de yugo de deux
éléments essentiels pour un humour qui
laisse les idées et les bactéries les
bactéries jo gook 100 euros la tonne en
latin streptococcus thermophilus
lactobacillus débris qui ces espèces
pluviales cus thériault gour pour un
lait de coco c'est un peu dire que tous
les champagnes senti qu elle
alors sur certains emballages ont
inscrit simili alternative ou de culture
le premier moteur d'innovation s'il
désire le deuxième c'est la naturalité
puis le troisième c'est la santé donc là
on va aller jouer sur le côté plaisir on
valoir une texture un goût intéressant
possiblement con côté nutritionnel aller
chercher des équivalents c'est le côté
naturalité cela personnes pensent qu'ils
valent autant un produit de plus naturel
possible il faut se poser des questions
sans pas avoir de secret a ajouté nous
avons demandé à hélène baribeau
nutritionniste d'analyser l'offre pour
se rendre compte qu'il n'y a pas de
produit parfait parfois trop gras trop
sucré pas assez protéinée sans vitamine
il est difficile de s'y retrouver si on
parle de remplacer un yo gourd nature
l'autre la version la plus naturelle
je dirais que c'est une minorité de
produits qui seraient similaires en
termes de valeur nutritive et aussi de
niveau de transformation
en fait un yo gourd contient toujours
des protéines des vitamines comme le
calcium et des bactéries
alors que dans le cas des produits
végétaux tout est variable
pourtant ce sont des protéines végétales
comme le recommande le nouveau guide
alimentaire canadien
on espère beaucoup on recommence
beaucoup d'elle de se tourner vers les
protéines végétales donc les aliments
qui contiennent des protéines végétales
même si la noix de coco et du règne
végétal
elle n'est pas une source de protéines
dans le canton prendre la loi coco
empreintes des grosses assuré
essentiellement et plusieurs marques
sont à base de coûts coûts par exemple
leçon consomme ce petit dessert
végétalien là par portion on va avoir 45
pour sein de ses à part un gros saturé
quotidien ça veut dire que si on en
prend deux dans sa journée on a presque
100% nous apparaît en gros saturer les
acides gras saturés du qu'aucun ne sont
pas plus recommandé que les acides gras
saturés du règne animal c'est sûr qu'une
personne végétaliens vegan sont à part
en acides gras saturés probablement
faible mais pour une personne qui mange
encore de la viande des produits
laitiers qui sont parfois plus riches en
gras saturés a ajouté des pros des
desserts à base de lait de coco ça sera
pas toujours une bonne idée surtout
c'est faire de façon régulière ou gras
saturés s'ajoute pour certains beaucoup
de sucre
ça c'est le produit quand même très
riches en sucre 7 grammes pour une
petite portion qu'on est vraiment ici
dans un désert quand même assez
calorique d'autres produits affiche qui
contiennent des probiotiques
on doit garantir que par portions et 1
milliards de bactéries oxo c'est une
autre obligation que l'industriel doit
respecter dire probiotiques sur un
produit c'est faire une allégation et
puis c'est parce qu'on associe à de la
santé donc on peut avoir un lait de coco
au lait d'amande lait de soya fermenté
donc on va dire de culture on pourra pas
non plus associer des fesses ou la santé
alors me maîtrise le grec grec nature
tout comme les young ur de produits
laitiers très sucré les versions végétal
peuvent tous ces êtres considérés comme
des desserts nous ont ajouté de la
protéine de poids et de misola de
protéines de pommes de terre pour un
meilleur choix il ya les produits à base
de soya ou encore ceux qui sont enrichis
de protéines et de vitamines
le soya est naturellement riche en
protéines donc on n'a pas besoin
d'ajouter de protéger le produit
il conseille aussi du calcium très peu
de gras saturés parce que c'est une
légumineuse ça c'est déjà trois points
en faveur de l'alternative soya par
contre au niveau du goût ça plaît pas à
tous comparis les desserts à base de
cocoon d'autres noix les grandes
tendances sont là pour exister
la protéine végétale va avoir sa place
parce que ça prend un bon savoir-faire
pour faire de bons produits végétalien
ici mais à la barre son grand rêve les
laitiers les bons profils étions rendus
en place avant hugo nature votre jour
est bon pour la santé